[Musica]
inchiesta musicali mette allegria stella
tutti ragazzi e prendermi di questo
nuovo video sono fa vigente non ci siamo
in into the groove
ovviamente sarebbe in bloom è un pokémon
a parte gli scherzi ovviamente il titolo
sarebbe nel buio insomma in italiano
la cosa strana list o gioca deprimente
dove sono sono 16 giudizio non ho visto
nessuno per e vabbè ho capito se imposto
di merda ci mancherebbe siamo già
partiti ragazzi come al solito è partito
dicendo dove sono insomma non si sa
neanche qua come ci siamo arrivati vole
volevo spiegarmi che cosa era mai già
partito a me non importa è un gioco
fatto a pixel
se non altro non ha scuse a mia madre
per dirmi una bella giornata vai a
giocare fuori 20 ragazzi non siamo
affatto a pixel tipo tipo aimi scared
loro paese genere è un rewind will play
firmato amazon capi perché ci sono delle
mani sul muro tra l'altro chiediamo ha
dato le manate salve è stato assassinato
non hanno credo stesse giocando al
impiccato un modo un po più serio e
posso toccarlo stock arti il birillo
cos'è un corpo abeto chi ha fatto questo
non lo so ma sinceramente non me ne
frega una mazza di scoprirlo quindi
andiamo avanti siamo trovato in ospedale
cos'è sta roba è bloccato tutte le porte
bloccate ovviamente fantastico mi fa
piacere iniziare a giocare ad un horror
fatto a pisa che ha posto uscire fuori a
giocare fantacci una chiave posso
prendere il mio braccio non c'arriva sì
ma minchia azionario come fai non prendo
la gioia davanti cioè vabbè non importa
la prima un'altra strada
ma c'è un'altra porta lia perfetto da
passato da dietro pareggi perché è pieno
di sangue sul muro ragazze cosa che poi
sto gioco si vede il bianco e nero
e l'appello e la peso e un altro colore
è nota cosa gli sta prendendo la sua
vendetta
ok io non ho fatto un cazzo quindi non
importa una donna che sportellate in
faccia non è al 100 fantastico lui lui
ti sta guardando sì proprio fare a meno
1 mentre cavo c'è almeno a meno la
privacy
ho trovato un tubo ha così fosse fornire
la chiave perfetto veicolo chiave
credo che possa prendere la chiave con
questo forse no perfetto non posso
prendo una mazza la cosa mi serve sto
tubo noi filone no minchia valtellina
sarebbero equipaggiare le cose allora ma
di interesse cosa che ne so io l'ho
presa
ok ragazzi ho preso la chiamano non sa
neanche che tasto premuto l'hanno presa
adesso io sono a controllare tipo 420
porte per vedere quale apre tipo il 6
quindi i costi sta riprendendo la sua
vendetta si ma me lo può fare perché io
voglio 18 ovviamente ragazzi siamo già
in un posto delle balle figuriamoci
saniamo di sotto che cosa può succedere
cos'è sta roba che lasciar lasciamo
perdere non importa per buongiorno siamo
sono fa vj se qualcuno per caso ha
voglia di alves è tale per casa visto
che è stato qui no perché c'è un tizio
che si sta prendendo vendetta ma vuole
giocare al tris ma visto lo subito le
rispetta come si deve a sing it e non so
come entrai qual è allora probabilmente
hai perso la prima giocava l'impiccato
le sue giocatrici
molto cos'è sto cazzo è sta roba
devo cosa devo fare tipo un labirinto ma
la ragazza non ha cambiato stasera ci
metterò qualcosa tipo 45 orebro vabbè ci
proviamo ragazzi dopo 45 minuti a
cercare di risolvere spavento credo che
cosa veramente sempre devi è una roba
che io io la schiaccia mi crea le strade
c'è veramente il pimi crea delle strade
nuove dove passare meglio ragazzi devo
farmi percorso da da qua a qua una cosa
pazienza e mm anni probabile bello
difficile così almeno non ci arriverò
mai vado a sinistra poi tutto su e poi
alla fine a destra c'è venete un casino
allora ok 12 fosse qua qua a destra
direttamente poi sinistra di nuovo ci
siamo ci sarebbe legati al mercato
beccato un tizio o brutto che stava qui
perché mi ha fatto non me l'aspettavo è
sicuramente che cos'è è chiuso bisogno
di una chiara ma quante chiavi non ha
rivisto gioco vabbè c'è un aggio una
scala portante ragazzi a trovare da
trovare la scala che andasse ancora più
sotto sia meno sono belle incasinato
perfetto dove siamo adesso
vabbè ragazzi che estate fa caldo però
cazzo il ventilatore potevano anche non
anche risparmiarsela facciamo prima
cos'è sta roba questa parte ha bisogno
in attesa la chiave è un'altra porta qua
aiuto io ve lo trovo mani sul muro cosa
cos'è sta roba
per me è sono fa vj sono cosa vi sta
guardando lui in agguato 2t cache a lui
ti ucciderà corri ok non mi piace
leggere stronzate sul muro quindi cambia
cambiamo completamente stanza perché è
meglio ma perché ci sono sedi a caso in
stanza caso divani passiamo da ikea va
bene tu sei stato un luci un lucidatore
fantastico cosa mi serve questo divano è
una cosa meravigliosa che qui affanculo
vaffanc cos'era falco segue la roba che
spunta ogni tanto c'è l'ok a pasto non
ne posso andiamo andiamo via perché già
mi sta tartassando i maroni ragazzi
trovano da cosa bellissima guardata
scala perché cazzo si gira verso di me
scale paranormali caso se tizio hai
qualche un suggerimento di bello e ho
trovato questa roba che un lubrificante
ami è avvenuto lontano metta nel c'è un
coso segnato lì non è grave arrivare
fino a lì allora il quadrato in mezzo
per quella destra credo non lo so credo
debba andare allora prima a destra prima
a sinistra e poi di nuovo a destra
perfetto credo di riuscirci sinistra
primo a destra se se se botta di culo
pazza e no basta da non possa mettere la
valvola nel tubo è troppo sporco allora
metropolia si si si
funziona può bambini già che botta di
culo basta unito due oggetti a caso
completamente a caso ma è avere gli
undici che avevo però almeno quello cioè
se non funzionava così ma basta invitare
gente ma che avranno più i suoi oli che
sei stato sembra sembrano non ciò che
non va beh lasciamo perdere ogni porta
andiamo avanti
è una cosa bruttissima impicca gente per
divertimento ancora devo capire non è
che fantasia quei piani comunque fa il
fantastico
tutti tutti diversi veramente tutti
diversi uno dall'altro non c'è merenda
non giocare letti a caso c'è salve senta
lei perché la stessa altezza pisa me
questa è la prendo è la preferendo la
tessera grazie
casini aver mangiato lasagna e sta
digerendo ma regalano capitano la
tessera però c'è un tizio che mi urla
nelle orecchie sta cosa mi piace poco
effettivamente quindi chi ha affermato
le pale centrale senza i qualcuno mi
stupri o cosa grazie
chiudi più di chiudi veloce bravissimo
però cosa bella che ci sono divani
ovunque meno quello che ho fatto una
chiave con un cartellino rosso
fantastico se me ne faccio due spiegare
qualcuno che legge che serve ad aprire
una delle porte che ho trovato
all'inizio sempre che ci riesca ad
arrivare prima che qualcuno mi ammazzi
ok qualcuno nessuno mi ha preso però
stranamente nessuno mi ha ucciso cosa
molto simpatica quindi provava da aprire
sta roba se si è fatta via via più
veloce veloce bene così regata linee
tipo siamo usciti siamo usciti a me vado
a giocare fuori grazie ho messo 40
minuti a trovare una chiave per uscire
da un tombino amico mio che cazzo si
faceva in un tombino di preciso se va
beh io certe cose continuano a non
capirle ma meglio lasciar meglio lasciar
perdere le saux salire le scale video e
poi le scale continuare di essere
paranormali quindi qui ancora non ho
capito come mai magari andiamo avanti la
samp da questa cosa perché non lo so
dove sta andando
ci sto andando in cima a un palazzo lodo
suicidarmi
entro la finestra tipo ladro entrato in
una casa a minchia quindi non so mi fa
piacere che anche più giocata al
impiccato nave lasciamo cadere con gli
impiccati andiamo avanti tanto bella
casa complimenti signora veramente figo
a credere di essere perfetto sono uscito
non funziona perché non funzionerà se
devo prendere l'ascensore rega credo
troviamo qualcosa che faccia funzionare
l'ascensore ci sarà un pannello per far
funzionare elettricità almeno spero
almeno quello
salve posso far funzionare al si salvi
anche a lei che giocano implicato
l'elettricità si sa merda devo ospitarlo
prima non c'è il cacciavite che ne so
cioè cacciavite per caso ancora ci sono
delle scale che non qua soprattutto
affetto allora bello ma qualcuno te l'ha
mai detto che non si sradicano le porte
c'è un tizio che ha sradicato
probabilmente una porta e che impicca
[ __ ] forti timori di merni caduto dal
cestino gr grazie dio grazie molto bello
6 permettere che voi cosa musica di
sottofondo cioè spacca e sta cosa cioè
mi fa prendere infatti con una musica
carina salvo salvati sì ma perché mai
non ci sapete giocare al impiccato non
comprate le vocali cos'è sta roba
viceprefetto trovato casa vita a regate
che avete sentite io mi dispiace devo
lasciarvi perodo segno che la cosa è più
tetra che la gente si gira a guardarmi
mentre impiccata fantastico proviamo a
svitare perfetto energia benissimo non
so neanche il piano deve andare il
preciso meno freddo perché tanto meglio
di parti penso vada bene qualsiasi posto
cos'è sta roba appello bel parcheggio e
grande posso prendere una macchina lo so
posso guidare una macchina andare via
dei [ __ ] novero ci mancherebbe
mettono le macchine a caso come dire
bello ci sono le macchine ma tu non le
puoi usare fantastica voglio vado avanti
di qua al tremonti casini sa che ci sono
permesso
gioca so cos'è boschivo cos'è chi sei tu
bell'uomo cos'è due sono due mi ha
portato e ma allora sei stronzo vedi
quando mangi le lasagne di mia nonna
come ridicoli mente ragazzi credo di
aver capito da quel poco che ho letto di
end è finito è finito così
no davvero cazzo che hanno non può
finire così scherziamo che lo riassumo
io come ho capito perché ho capito poco
che c'era un tizio che è andato in coma
viveva in una realtà alternativa dove ci
sono dove c'è sta gente bella veramente
bella e io l'ho quel tizio che camminava
fantastico ragazzi cioè non ho capito un
cazzo però tagli concludere qui
l'episodio perché non mi so spiegare
quello che appena giocato ma va bene
così
i ragazzi se il video è piaciuto ma
sempre stato momento mi piace anche al
cagliari facebook e povero di video
trovate nella dedizione senza doversi
dimettere